cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I'll tell you what the
problem is though they have a Kamala
Harris problem it's a significant
problem it's true the pro the problem is
I don't think it's the way you think I'm
gonna say it the Kamala Harris problem
is
they cannot it's not right okay
skip her over I I especially a white guy
no wait there is a solution though
AOC Michelle Obama oh you're right will
she I mean she says no I mean you made
more insight than I am we don't hang out
okay I'm surprised I was shocked here
that I'm sorry that I was misinformed
um she decided that she wanted to enter
The Fray I think not only she win the
nomination she wins the election and it
creates by the way probably without even
contesting a primary or a general
because she would simply walk into the
convention Joe Biden would have an
instant medical need to depart and at
the convention it would be viewed as
this kind of dramatic unifying electric
moment she would walk in the Michelle
Obama banners would would go up and and
that would be a uh far more formidable
opponent than Joe Biden if Michelle
Obama decided to run I wouldn't be
surprised if Joe Biden and Joe Biden
said I you know guys I'm getting a
little old for this and no one's better
than Michelle I worked with her you have
my word that that could work Biden
bowing out with Michelle coming in
doesn't negatively impact on that that
what evidence suggests she wants the job
no it doesn't uh and I'm not convinced
that it will be Michelle I think Gavin
Newsom and my so my advice to the Deep
State you would agree that Michelle
Obama would be a tougher general
election candidate than to defeat than
than Gavin Newsom right oh yeah yeah I
think I think if Michelle Obama runs she
wins I don't know how the Rock's dinner
right behind her on the stage there
there are some challenges and I will
stress this okay my opinions change I'm
not saying it's going to be a landslide
or anything for Michelle Obama I'm
saying that it would be very very
difficult to overcome someone who who
doesn't have the negatives of of Barack
because she wasn't the one bombing kids
and uh isn't as active in politics it's
a clean slate high-profile celebrity
personality
however but like didn't she push the
fitness thing well yeah and then get
thick well what happened because she was
pushing the let's move Campaign which
was an anti-sugar move and then they got
in and the big sugar came to her and
they're like why don't you make it an
exercise campaign Michelle she was like
but okay that's and then she changed
tone to an exercise thing it was about
sugar it was about getting rid of the
sugar industry I don't I don't see that
as being material to a modern election
what I mean what what's going to happen
Trump's going to come out and be like
remember when she was giving those kids
sugar and they were fat and or whatever
and they're gonna be like who cares who
cares so so but here's what I would say
I think on Celebrity Status in that
respect I don't know what Trump can can
do can do to beat her well I shouldn't
say that I'm probably being a little bit
too hyperbolic what I mean is there is a
possibility that the economy is just too
bad and there's a lot of people who are
like I'm sick of the whiteness Michelle
Obama would have to embrace the
progressive left which is is is tanking
Democrats and the left right now if you
look at Bud Light and Target and Disney
and all these companies Disney losing
what like billions of dollars or
whatever on their last 10 releases so
there's real reason to believe that the
cultural moves made by the Democrats are
toxic for the Democratic party and
that's Trump's Advantage right now but
you just imagine being in the room when
they tell Kamala Harris that Michelle
Obama is entering the race oh that looks
blood I think she wants it
I believe that
Kamala Chase every time they shake hands
dude I have never seen somebody more
politically Craven
come on she was willing to date Willie
Brown to move what do you mean that's
not easy yeah well let me give you my
hypothetical so our viewers all know
this one but here's my hypothetical this
is my advice to the Deep state right
obviously Joe Biden's a liability for
the Democratic party the The
Establishment the DNC powerful interests
they need to find a way to get a better
candidate so my my imagined scenario
conspiracy theory is that Joe Biden is
doing a campaign rally in California has
a medical episode
grasps his chest stumbles Falls Gavin
Newsom Runs Out saves the day you think
it's too late to do that it's too late
and B Gavin Newsom was almost recalled
in his own State that's true he smoked
that recall
yes and no at the end he did I'll tell
you what happened yeah he was losing
yeah that recall what happened was was
that Larry Elder was actually making
strides and the so what then what after
Larry Elder pulled at the top he was
literally about to about to win that and
then the the big money was the tech
money we were sitting on the sidelines
the big Tech money said whoa whoa whoa
whoa you're telling me that Larry Elder
might be a replacement then the tech
money flowed in and that's when his
numbers changed he was going to lose
that recall until the tech Bros decided
we're gonna weigh in however listen your
record is which you are what your record
says you are this guy beat a recall Beat
It massively in an off-year election
when he'd locked down Californians now
I'm mad I'm married to a California and
I know this about them they do not like
to be locked down like you take someone
from Minnesota and you lock them down
they're locked down like eight nine
months of the year anyway right so it's
not that big a deal they got like cool
indoor things to do you take these
Californians who like are used to eating
outside and like doing all these things
and you tell them that they're a
lockdown and these people go crazy and
they showed up and voted for Gavin
Newsom anyway there are restaurants in
in Southern California that are just
outside there's like no roof because the
weather's always so nice
food trucks as somebody from California
I spent a lot I spent half my time in
California doing the lockdown dude they
were sheep The Californians were sheep
they they did whatever they were told to
do with the lockdown do you want me to
hike outside I'm not gonna hike outside
can't Surf not gonna surf I can't tell
you the stories I had of I remember I
was walking down the street one time in
LA and I wasn't wearing a mask outside
because I refused to wear a mask outside
look inside if you want to wear a mask
I'll wear one outside I just refused to
do it and one watt was a hurstling
behind me I heard murderer murderer I'm
like where what the hell's going on holy
crap what's going on I see she's face
she's like Instagram live in me she's
like you're killing people by walking
around without a mask excuse me I can't
I can't hear you
I can't I can't read your lips
I don't know like ultimately the only
thing that seems to make sense is that
the the the corporate press and the
Democrats are outright admitting Biden
can't win well this is my question
because I think that Trump and this is
something that comes up on the show and
God forbid this happens I hope it
doesn't but that he's taken off the
ballot in at least one state because
some guy somebody in some states like he
no he committed a crime I don't want one
then they maybe the legislative maybe
they'll go take it to the Supreme Court
it'll get overturned but it'll be too
late by that point that he because he's
only on the ballot in 49 states he can't
win it's a lost cause I'm pointing at
Vivek it's like let's at least there's
somebody but like I think what do you
guys even think that well yeah come
October next year there's going to be
one state or some jurisdiction that's
got balanced with no without Trump on
them there's no way that's going to
survive review by the fellowships
we have a system of injunctions and like
right peoples that will resolve that but
but it doesn't matter okay because if
look what happens in Arizona on Election
Day you get 19-inch bouts on one inch
paper or whatever the machines get
jammed up and it happens it's going to
be election day people are going to go
to the polling locations and polling
locations are going to have bouts where
Trump's name is smudged removed or
whatever well guess what we're going to
need this time that we didn't have left
last time a real legal strategy like
Ronald McDaniel is it did such a bad job
as the head of the RNC and frankly I
wish she was not leading that
organization currently but they were all
interested in promotion and brand
building but there's a certain amount of
like lawyering and being ready to get
those injunctions right then because the
key difference is once you get polluted
ballots intermingled with non-polluted
ballots you're never going to have any
judge in the country that's going to
exercise jurisdiction to go and unwind
that so let's say in Arizona on Election
Day 2024 not the early votes not the
mail-in votes just the in-person votes
Trump's name is missing
you get your injunction filed what do
they do do they stop the election yes
you go and immediately and join the
election you'll get a court to say that
you are disenfranchising those voters at
that exact time and the election must
must stop my concern is based on what
we've seen with Kerry Lake in particular
with us finding out immediately the
bouts were bunk like the bouts were
wrong and did not work immediately and
then the judges are like nah and now
we're you know we're like a year later
and she's winning these these these
cases they ruled the signature
verification was was being done
illegally right but what about winning
on the remedies that's what I'm saying
what I'm saying is if if you do not
obtain immediate relief not file a
lawsuit you know you have to go and get
relief
you have to stop the election that's a
big ask of a judge and I don't think
they're gonna yeah but if you don't if
you don't have ballots with someone's
name on it you're presenting a really
severe hypothesis with Carrie Lake I
love Kerry Lake I think more people
intended to vote for Kerry Lake the
nintendent vote for Katie Hobbs and it's
a great travesty she's not Governor but
there were also some self-inflicted
wounds there like you know when I'm
willing to take someone's vote anytime
they're willing to give it to me and
when you drive your voters to one
particular day and one particular vote
method you invite a vulnerability
so the the concern I have I suppose is
it's not so simple as to say we need an
injunction on this election right now
because Trump's name's on the ballot and
then get immediate relief a few problems
how could there be immediate relief we
need to stop the election postpone let's
get an injunction immediately go walk to
the courthouse there's a duty judge
that's on so this means the election
wants to take place a week from now
after we reprint the mouse and get them
fixed however the second thing is and I
don't know if it'll be Arizona that does
this or I think there's a possibility
that happens the Secretary of State then
says we legally and legitimately took
his name off the ballot under the 14th
Amendment so before you get your
injunction we get a chance to argue why
we did it sure well that's an injunction
hearing they'll have like they'll have
like an hour to argue it but but if they
already print the ballots you'll be
arguing day of during the election and
the judge will have to say I nullify
today's results I I it is within the
power of a court to provide that relief
in real time without without uh
arguing something I mean if this is
going to go down
this was this is what already had been
done before the
elections were the Attorney General of
the state is going to be all of a sudden
on the day of election take the name off
I think it's going to be done beforehand
then Arizona
the the the ballots were printed wrong
the files were changed at hundreds of
locations I I don't know how that's
possible unless someone intentionally
goes and manually changes the setting
and I think that was the determination
that all of these uh was a couple
hundred voting voting machine locations
had the wrong ballots for the wrong
machine arguing the 14th Amendment
argument that they're making you're not
arguing they're taking them off the
ballot because he doesn't shouldn't
qualify no I'm sorry I am what I'm
saying is if they can create the bad
ballots and have them ready on election
day without anyone knowing they
certainly can do the same thing and say
I didn't need to inform you that there
was a 14th Amendment determination I
think it would be really really hard to
maintain the results of an election like
that where someone unilaterally without
notice decides they're going to remove a
candidate's name I agree but in Arizona
they did this they didn't know they
didn't you know I I I understand but the
ballots did not work in the machines
they were made for and that was done
unilaterally at hundreds of locations
disenfranchising voters and the only
argument they have uh in favor of Hobbes
was oh but don't worry nobody nobody
would vote nobody lost their vote
because of it and that's a nebulous
argument you did not count we can't
track those numbers the vote was busted
in in Arizona like you don't think
there's going to be one state that does
okay let's say it's not even taking
Trump's name off the ballot I don't
think so let's say uh New Hampshire the
the ballots uh uh are printed on the
wrong size Whoopsie Daisy and then
they're going to say well too bad you
know we we believe nobody was
disenfranchised from this case closed
and the question is and I'll throw it to
Texas V Pennsylvania in 2020. I was
talking about this earlier it was the
correct decision of Ken Paxton to file
the suit it was the correct decision of
Alito and Thomas to say the Supreme
Court should hear this this this case
but the rest the justices in my view
were probably sitting there being like
I'm not going to be responsible for a
contingent election
there there's gonna I I'm willing to
believe that's exactly right right a
bunch of these judges when it came to
2020 it's not a question of fraud I I
I've never been a big fan of like oh
they bounce printed in China Dominion
the issue was Texas argued that four key
States altered their election rules
outside of the legislature through
Executives or through the Judiciary and
that is not constitutionally allowed and
there needs to be a review on this that
is true and correct if you read the
Constitution the state legislatures have
ultimate say and some of these
legislatures were actually asking Trump
and asking States hey we did not agree
to these terms with universal mail and
voting Etc some did Pennsylvania the GOP
teamed up and they and they made these
changes but the judges just would not
they threw out they threw out all these
things on standing so the merits are
never even heard my fear for 2024 were I
don't I don't know how we have let me
pause I'll put it this way Steven Marsh
I referenced this guy a lot he wrote a
book I think he wrote with Andrew Yang
called the last election and I think
they're making the argument that 2024
could be the last election but if your
argument the argument that he's made on
all these issues would actually indicate
that 2020 was the last election however
based on the perspective of trump
supporters 2016 was the last election
full stop Democrats think Russia
interfered to get Trump elected which
means 2012 was the last real election we
ever had look I I'll tell you my issue
with all these arguments and like it's a
and it's an issue I have with another
issue I have with Trump is that he keeps
talking about fine the election was
stolen the election was stolen
without having a solution right which
means that what what's to stop the
election being stolen again which look
when this come when this whole thing
doesn't come out to turn out right at
the end of the day what's going to
determine who's gonna win it's gonna be
turn out and all you're doing and this
is what you did frankly with Georgia
right you were just depressing turnout
and that's why we lost Georgia that's
why we lost the Senate and I think it's
we also had terrible candidates in
Georgia the canis worked well they they
I think I think the fraud narrative
helped everyone one of them in
particular was terrible but but the the
Heap he look this is a huge issue that I
will never I just I just I I can't look
at Trump and say you know I I take your
apology it just he lost the Senate
because he pushed people not to vote
there was uh we had a uh Democrat
politician on the the cultural War show
Friday mornings who said I ran ads of
Trump's statements to disenfranchise
Republican voters of course of course I
fully you have to give Georgia credit
because they're alleged legislature came
into session and they do have better
signature verification laws they do have
better ballot custody laws it's not
perfect I don't love the way things are
run in Fulton and DeKalb County but
there's at least more opportunity for
State lawmakers to put those local
jurisdictions into some sort of legal
receivership when they start breaking
the law so there's been some progress in
Georgia we should Champion that I would
I would not be surprised if in 2024 you
have in uh Republican swing state areas
whoops the ballots were smudged for Joe
Biden and then in Democrat areas whoops
the bouts were smudged for Trump
something happening procedurally because
if you look at Arizona as the key
example of this with Kerry Lake I don't
understand how any judge could
reasonably say that election is sound
when the ballots were wrong like I'm
sorry like if you can if I was a judge
someone came to me and said hey the
wrong voucher printed I'm like oh wow we
better have a new election no questions
asked done out out you look at that and
my concern now is why would Republicans
not play the same game and say okay in
the jurisdictions we have more control
over what the secretary of state that we
need to win let's Whoopsie Daisy some
ballots and then Democrats will just do
the same thing that happened in Arizona
that goes to a very ugly place my man I
know I agree it's already you can't
resolve these differences through
elections then you know history tells us
that uh it's a it's a far darker place
that people go I don't like the path of
using dirty tactics I think that what
you were saying Ami is that like if we
we should offer Solutions like yeah
maybe the votes were hacked back in the
day if you I've got Clinton Eugene
Curtis testifying in front of Congress
that he built software that flips votes
5149 okay that's on Congressional
testimony knowing that developers can
flip votes 51.49 and you don't see it
makes me wonder that maybe maybe we
should fortify against that maybe we
should start backing up our votes on a
blockchain somewhere somewhere that's
immutable that we can reference so we
don't have to rely on a private
Corporation to tell us what our vote
tallies were yeah let me ask you Matt do
you think there's uh any any uh appetite
among Democrats or any chance they would
support a bill that would make voting
machines code open source uh yes there
are there are Democrats who particularly
look at blockchain as a tool that can be
used in in election integrity and so uh
it's the only not blockchain I'm just
saying whatever blockchain actually I
was I was answering specifically what
what Ian was saying because there are
folks who believe that that would be a
way to really validate these things and
create a standard for the world the the
code for these machines needs to be
publicly available I don't know that we
can really do that I don't know that we
can go tell someone that they have to
put their make their code open source uh
well I suppose you're right States need
to do it right it's not a federal
question so yeah you're I was wrong
about that and you know the other thing
is is and this also pissed me off is I
think it was Megyn Kelly who's
interviewing Trump and she said look the
Democrats are ballot harvesting will you
ballot Harvest there's only one answer
to that the answer is yes yes that's the
answer the answer is not I don't know I
don't think so because you got he was
why because he was upset about
harvesting costing the election last
time which by the way totally understand
totally that's part of the of the part
of his conspiracy I can get I get on
with that's not a conspiracy that's what
happened but the only answer is that's a
tactic that look you were talking about
the that's a tactic they're using it
would be political malpractice not to do
the same thing well Trump did say it
happened when we are doing I mean I give
a lot of credit to Charlie Kirk and
turning point because they they have
operationalized a lot of young people to
get involved in getting folks to make
their ballot requests showing back up
when that request is made bring a stamp
if you have to tell somebody to put it
in the mailbox get the ballot put it in
the Dropbox I mean that work is being
we're finally building that
infrastructure
it should be the Republican Party doing
that they have failed and so it's a
group like Turning Point dude it's so
important that we open up the voting
voting machine so we can see their
tallying tactics because there's no
greater threat in my opinion to American
the American way of life then
International technocracy and if people
are trying to control our elections on
voting machines behind the scenes like
that is absolute tyranny whether for
good or evil it's tyranny they have
control of our system it has to stop and
maybe completely correct you're saying
it has to begin with the state the
States run their own elections so the
federal government's not going to
regulate what California or Illinois
does but then you don't want that by the
way right in Florida it was actually the
Democrats who said this technology with
the pimple Chads and The dimple Chads
after the bush V Gore matter they wanted
paper ballots so now in Florida anytime
there's any funny business where people
got concerns about machines or
tabulation there's a requirement for
paper ballots there's a chain of custody
for those paper ballots there are
retention requirements for those paper
ballots and it's led to a to a pretty
high functioning system
oh that's good I still I this is why
people gotta vote locally and and too
many people look to federal government
to solve problems that federal
government cannot solve can you guys
from the federal government issue like
suggestions to States well here's an
idea uh back when school choice was
really emerging in the thought space of
conservatism you Congress was looking to
get involved but we believed education
was primarily a state function but there
is one place that we have exclusive
jurisdiction and it's Washington DC and
so Congress did DC education vouchers
they drove down the cost they increased
the quality and then that became a model
for places like Florida where we've
expanded school choice so one idea is
that you take whatever is the gold
standard for elections on signature
verification election day voting voter
ID not letting illegal aliens vote you
know uh all the Jim Crow stuff yeah
right right apparently take all that
stuff and say these are the new election
laws for Washington D.C and there you're
you're putting it over an overlay of a
primarily Democrat uh area but you could
model that and see if it was replicated
so like a blockchain backup system like
seven blockchains where everything's you
can go high-tech or low-tech you know
our paper ballots better than blockchain
I think it's a reasonable debate but but
we could actually design a model system
uh without violating our concepts of
federalism yeah I think it would be both
paper and backed up on a blockchain so
you could reference the two who would
have to put that in order it would be
Congress yeah we have a committee the
house administration committee that has
jurisdiction over this and it's
precisely what the chairman told me he's
working on an Ideal election Integrity
bill for Washington D.C that that we
hope would uh would draw favor elsewhere
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time